sauf que l'histoire est assez universel
c'est un polar mais c'est encore un
drame pour moi qu'un polar comme seuls à
faire cela il faut aller vite
depuis longtemps depuis plusieurs années
je reçois des scénarios régulièrement
américain beaucoup de ceux que je reçois
sont ce qu'ils appellent dérivés après
sa dérive en chemise et je trouvais que
zoulou c'était il y avait matière
justement pour faire un bouquin qui soit
le contre-pied de ça il soit un thriller
un polar avec effectivement de la
violence mais qui soit un bouquin sur
sur le pardon et la beauté du président
du pardon
etc
le baulois j'ai appelé mon agent pour me
renseigner ou était le bouquin qui
avaient des droits
et voilà on s'est rencontrés après que
richard vampire le producteur mais c'est
simple je veux sa version venant ici
aussi que finalement le fait d'être un
étranger donc de ne pas avoir de passer
chez d'africains de n'être ni black ni
nicolas reny afrikaans ça me donnait un
avantage en fait c'est que j'avais pas
je vais pas ni de poids de culpabilité
ne fallait pas de passé donc je me
sentais plus libre sans doute pour
parler avec avec chacun sans avoir
ménages américains
c'est un choix dont je n'ai qu'à me
féliciter
c'est un plaisir et je sais que lui il a
le même plaisir il vous plaît tous les
jours ces familles vivent aussi lisse
plus démunis
d'autres acteurs amis
les gens autour de moi les en assistant
aux facs au type quand les gens se
parlent entre eux ça remonte de manière
indirecte
j'ai l'impression voilà les gens
trouvent le scénario pour une option
pour être écrit par un sud africain
c'est juste à propice à voir qu'à foot à
galway moi c'était mon angoisse c'est un
truc comme parfois font les américains
quand il veut faire un film en france où
ça sonne tout sonne un peu faux ou le cd
détail c'est bizarre film mais c'est une
manière de s'habiller c'est une manière
de l'élève maire de pousser une porte
entre dans une boutique qui sont dit
bonjour pas bonjour c'est milliards de
détail d'arriver à se rapprocher de
cette vérité là d'un pays qui n'est pas
le tien
un vrai défi pas un petit père comme je
marque on va y arriver